labour is urging the government to
invest at least 30
billion pounds over the next 18 months
in a green recovery
in the process the hope is to create 400
000
new jobs uh pleased to say i'm joined
now by the shadow business secretary ed
miliband mr miller lovely to have you in
the studio
um so so take us through this there is
an awful lot of discussion
around investment in the green economy
plenty of eyes on you know what happens
after
for covid 19. it's an awful lot of money
it is but here's the thing we've got a
jobs crisis we know we've lost about a
million jobs
during the economic crisis caused by
coronavirus
we know we've got masses to do in
getting
our economy ready for the green
transition that we need to make and you
know that's everything from
industry we want our aerospace
manufacturers making the low-carbon
engines of the future
the electric vehicle charging points we
need to the
nature-based solutions the tree planting
to retrofitting homes
we're saying to government you're
planning to spend around 100 billion
pounds on infrastructure
during this parliament bring forward at
least 30 billion pounds of that for the
next 18 months
to provide a stimulus to the economy and
create hundreds of thousands of jobs
because we know people have lost their
jobs it's the right thing to do for the
for the job market but it's also the
right thing to do for the climate as
well i suppose the question is how
quickly those jobs can come on stream it
does rather
it does rather seem to me that sometimes
when we're talking about investment in
green technology
we're talking about an industry that is
very much in its infancy
well that's true to some extent but you
know take aerospace for example and i
spent a lot of time talking to the
aerospace manufacturers
they're saying to me government said
we'll spend about 150 million on getting
the low-carbon engines of the future
ready if they double that amount 300
million it could make a massive
difference to us
it could protect jobs and we're ready to
go on that we're ready to to develop
that technology
or something as simple as tree planting
you know we know that is a nature-based
solution
to the climate challenge we know it can
be done quickly or retrofitting homes
putting
the insulation which will cut bills and
also protect the planet
actually when you look across the
economy there are so many jobs crying
out to be done
and the other thing is neil is that we
get bang for our buck if we invest in
green or
the evidence of the last financial
crisis is that when there was investment
in green industry it's jobs rich so in
other words you get you get more bang
for your buck
uh it's value for money we've got to
spend this money anyway and it and it
and it makes for a better country at the
end of it
well let's see if the government pays
any ideas you can keep fingers crossed
on your back
but let's talk about perhaps the the
story of the day the final
um vaccine for covid19 how optimistic
are you
that but we had we had some plenty of
expectation management from the
government at the press conference
yesterday i have to say
how confident are you that if we haven't
turned the corner then we at least know
where the corner is now
i mean look i'm going on what the
scientists are saying just just like you
and the people watching this program
it feels like a more hopeful day than
we've had in a long time doesn't it
um from what the scientists are saying
but we need to be cautious and i think
the government is right to be cautious
and we can't ignore the fact that this
is going to go on for some time
and whether it's the businesses that i'm
talking to are saying we're still facing
real difficulty and we're going to
continue to hold the government to
account in a constructive way
to be supporting them sorting out the
test track and trace
which is still uh you know to be fair to
government a work in progress
so you know we still and we need to be
observing the rules as well
all of us so you know it sounds quite
hopeful
but let's not get ahead of ourselves i
mean if you were to try and put a time
scale in these things the
health secretary was was reluctant to do
so i'm i'm going to join him
but if the vaccine has rolled out in
december from your brief in terms of
business
you know where would you like to see
prioritization take place you want to
see businesses being able to get back to
normal
how can that happen with a with a
vaccine i think that's got to be
science-led you know
because because the scientists are
saying that as i understand it that we
should be starting with older people
which seems to me to
to make sense so i think you know in all
of this i'd say
we've got to be science-led and you know
the science has got to
tell us what we should be doing and in
the meantime we need that support for
businesses you know i'm still worried
that
lots of businesses are saying to me
we're not getting the same support that
we got at the beginning of the crisis
yes the furlough extension
finally is a good thing but we need
greater support to get us through the
crisis we're in a fragile position so in
a sense
i think the brief for someone like me is
to let the scientists and
the health experts worry about the
vaccine get it get that right
but in the meantime we still need to be
getting that support to business so so
10 out of 10 for the head of the vaccine
task force kate bingham
well i'm sure everybody played lots of
people played a role
uh in relation to that i mean there's
been some controversy about some of the
issues around kate bingham and some of
the way government money has been spent
i don't think those issues go away
um but obviously for everyone who's
developed this vaccine
it sounds hopeful it doesn't go away but
apparently she will at the end of the
year i'm just wondering what your view
is
of the spending of seven hundred
thousand pounds of seven hundred
thousand pounds worth of taxpayers money
on
pr consulting completely inexplicable um
i mean why you need a team of i think
ten ten consultants 10 pr consultants
um as well as all of the you know press
office and so on
i i i i don't understand it you know i
don't understand it i think we've got to
be really
careful about the way we spend taxpayers
money i don't think that's careful
that's being careful with taxpayers
money
um do you think she should have been uh
sacked rather than
as seems to be a one-year contract
hasn't been renewed
i i don't think somebody doing engaging
in that kind of
those practices should be carrying on in
their job put it that way
um whilst we have you i wonder what
advice
you might have for for donald trump on
how to lose an election gracefully
sorry uh
very good well done well done joe pike
um i'll be having words with him later
when i when i look when i lost the
election um
and i sort of you know you these things
are seared on your memory i you know i
rang up david cameron to congratulate
him
um and i accepted the result um and
that's what donald trump should be doing
you know i mean i sort of feel he's
going to carry on raging until january
the
the morning of january the 20th when joe
biden gets sworn in
look i think it is an important moment i
think it's an important
you know from my perspective joe biden's
victory is an important moment
for sort of decency um you know caring
about people treating people with
tolerance
for the climate issue which we've talked
about where you know
the donald trump got out of the the
paris accord on climate change the
international accord and
joe biden saying one of his first
accident get get america back in so
those are important things hey melbourne
we are just out of time thank you very
much for joining us in the studio